bonjour bonjour bonjour d'invités
bonjour ici qu'est ce que c'est que
cette superbe bête que vous avez
aujourd'hui dans les mains c'est mon
magnifique et qu'un autre rappelle
combien dans le sait qu'ils ont quand
même si kiwi est bien avec ce qu'anna
gravats et eva nous préparer aujourd'hui
une recette particulièrement délicieuse
qui utilise essentiellement pour
commencer le coût du canari alors pour
faire des poules farcies puisque c'est
de ça qu'il s'agit mais était qu'est-ce
que vous allez utiliser
eh bien il faut de la grèce de la
ventrèche du jambon des ailerons du foie
gras bien entendu des oignons de
l'échalote de l'aïd des piercings du sel
du poivre et le tourniquet de ficelle
avec l'aiguillon verra pour couronne on
verra pourquoi après alors il ya deux
manières de d'utiliser c'est too far ci
soit on peut les faire fuir et c'est
pour ça que nous avons déjà préparé la
friteuse avec beaucoup de bonnes
graisses de canard qui commence à fondre
de dona ou bien on peut l'espérer lisez
tout simplement dans des bocaux en
évoquant avec l'intention et socialement
de les manger bio les marges et fois
maïté nous a apporté maintenant quatre
coups avec la tête il ya plus de bec et
qu'est ce que vous allez en faire
maintenant on va le préparer c'est à
dire alors on va couper le cou à la tête
on va relever la tête 2
3 et 4 et après ensuite en décalant un
coup oui ça a l'air tout facile à vous
messieurs en laisse à l'envers on dirait
une chose faite
oui on enlève tout soit bien droit et
surtout qu'il n'y ait pas de trou à
north bay de là où il faut faire
attention qu'ils soient pas coupés
on dirait une gigantesque girone non
elle avait bien les graciant peut
terminer ça qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
enlever la soupe on ne gaspille pas
quand même faire vous mettez de côté
vous le mettez de l'angleterre deux
autres elle est alors maintenant coup
alors cliquer là que c'est du coton
était jolie on rit on peut faire sauver
la fille soeur skoda et il va couper
aller en europe ou faut pas que ça
glisse est terminée et on fait un petit
peu insurgés par le petit bout
oui ah oui du côté de la côte est
voilà un bon petit sûr j'ai aussi
revient faut que ça tienne t'amène à huy
prouve pas que la farce martin enfin la
part la farce est grosse et puis j'ai
pas très doué pour la culture non plus
en fait pas si mal faire faire que c'est
un peu dur parce que le filet gros donc
ça tient évidemment ça fasse pas de nous
on aura des gros points c'est vous savez
puis pas tous à la ligne alors là on est
au bout on refait le sens encore une
fois notre cash et non dans ce bar se
maintient alors on fait un nul quoi la
route soyez jeu kung fu et très bien
alors je rhdp comme une aiguille à laon
retourne le coup comme une chaussette
exemple l'agent 7
montrez-nous bien la couture là qu'on
voit comment ça se voit oui voilà très
bien et maintenant maïté il faudrait
penser à la farce
alors qu'est ce que nous annonce un oui
alors voir si nos ailerons on va aller
couper bien sûr regarde la peau ah oui
c'est ce qui calme pendant les violences
ça fait rien passé l'effet se fera pas
en cuisine en période non content comme
ça on enlève toute la viande on est ce
que l'os te fais pas mal finalement dans
un aileron de canard
ah ah oui une bonne quantité deuxième et
c'est là où on enlève le magret oiseaux
il reste voilà la vente ou le maigre bon
je le met dans la machine achi oui est
ce que la mesure
oui pour commencer à shebab alors je
commence à mettre tout souriant
on va prendre l'autre et je tourne un
peu voir la belle victoire pour m
d'abord entre temps m'a donné un petit
peu oui
toujours bon a ajouté on va mélanger le
genre dont tout va tout mélanger à
presser haut demba diop et effet ah oui
le belattar show à les voir là un peu de
l'euro ah oui j'ai pas fait de celui là
là un peu d'oignons
on y va oubliée la ventrèche non plus
mais dans le genre même besoin je sens
que j'ai appelé sans se mélanger
voilà ça c'est le pays vient trahir est
déjà là comme il faut on va vous la
donne et maintenant on la vend très cher
et tout ça ça va faire délicieux
vraiment on ajoute tous les hits on est
gamin il me manque les échalotes le père
si oui ou non les données d'hier tout ça
j'ajoute oui de l'union y en a c'est on
va remettre des échalotes un bouddha et
peut-être à huy et de persil aussi la 3
échalotes
parce qu'il faut pas que ce soit trop
lourd à l'oignon l'échalote est quand
même là je vais au lit avec les bonnes
choses qu'on est déjà dans la la je vais
mourir et j'ai pas mal à écraser la ja
on lâche et sépare toujours un peu
doctorat sont lassés gros ils
passeraient pas bien un bon petit coup
de hache pas pour la pluie
je gardais sommes vus comme vous nous
avez déjà expliqué précédemment
ça y est vous pouvez donner voilà
allons-y vite là on le met dedans on
ajoute le père si le père c'est mon
métier
aulas vient parfaire on rajoutera dans
la relation apparaît octobre et de trois
petits morceaux du rebond qui traînent
par là et tu vois là notre garde a agi
pour sceller l'accord sa rivale a ajouté
sa vague et peu à peu ça va très bien et
moi aussi ça va très bien je vais
maintenant coupé mon foie et oui un
carré et je vais le coupé grossièrement
pourquoi on le retrouve bien s'il faut
pas qu'ils font ne tellement faut qu'on
retrouve dans leur mission par le retour
des morceaux assez grand ces gros là
qu'il est joint un bébé sur un corps il
a eu chaud
on aurait cru là et maintenant vous
allez me faire passer la farce
voilà on va là ces zones et on va
pousser cette fois où je veux le même
mais le remettre dans l'assiette pour
pouvoir
assaisonner la farce sans démolir bien
le foie or là il va y aller avec la
maman j'ai ma petite main d'un petit
malaise quelqu'un vous amener à leur
mettant dans du sel du poivre
il faudra remettrai parce que toujours
de gros sel oui parce que c'est du
saint-louis toujours moi je me sers suis
là là et du poivre
tu voir nous lui devons lyon du conte
viennent mourir au dernier mais nous ne
regardez pas et quand même il en forêt
elle veut voir un petit soupçon comme
d'un soupçon un bon soupçon de poids
ayez pas peur de jouer ça on va tous ces
derniers les beaux et alors on mélange
un mélange et bayal ailleurs le persil à
l'oignon et fonds tient bien bien bien
manger tout je vais me lire que le
soupçon de poivre maïté is an mais
n'ayez pas peur au sel il en faut parce
que les gens bornés pas très salée
n'ayez pas peur et c'est maintenant
qu'on met le foie alors le foie on le
pose là je vais y mettre des yankees
tomber par terre tu avais pour lui il
avait tort je vais installer un petit
peu le foie veut mettre un petit peu de
pouvoir sur le foire même opération
remet l'argent pour qu'il y en ait un
bon partout et après ça c'est ça qu'on a
rempli le que le coup le couard je le
prends voilà j'ai pris plus beaux la
malaisie le message qu'elle se régaler
là et vous avez les merengues d'aller
chercher toute manière elles sont déjà
bien engagées
ces bons morceaux de faut aller voir des
cantons veulent couper tout à l'heure la
nourrir les siens
on va là je vous passe les guînes fille
j'ai les mains qui m'a glissé un petit
peu mais ça fait rien bon là il ya un an
on nie les faits et alors on rejoint là
on va le faire de ce côté là voilà je
vais pas vous dit m quand même les mains
il y en a c'est d'une vous savez combien
ça ne boude et un coup et c'est pareil
oulala on dirai pas quand il est vide et
on dirait pas compris le vide et puis ça
ressemble à tous qu'on cette espèce de
gros goût de la remettre debout
je vous le dis un peu l'arrière pour
rassembler les déportés à la faux bien
coudre oui mais ça par pages outre cela
il faut faire attention à ne pas se
déchirer car même et et ben oui ça va
être tirée par les chiffrer qu'est ce
que vous nous avez expliqué au départ je
voulais bien l'intention même avant
quand on a fait le coup si on l'achète
séparément qui n'est pas qu'une envie de
reprise soit pas une passoire spd
surgères on croirait kg large et toute
la journée
[Musique]
et pourtant ça glisse je peux vous dire
que c'est pas moi qui ai fait ça faut en
tout cas s'en va après l'épisode et
voilà vous allez voir infliger une scène
c'est une bonne partie de l'été il faut
pas de copine et voilà qu'après on a une
plus qu'épargné on espère garder ça deux
modes de cuisson pour ce coup car si tu
nous la vie tout à l'heure on peut le
faire stériliser dans un bocal pour le
manger froid ensuite alors on cerne bien
sûr un des confrères indiens pueblos au
bain marie et en os mais aubert marie
avec la précaution de mettre un caillou
dessus pour ne pas que le bocal face à
danser là il ya peu trop souvent ne
sortira resté combien de temps là dedans
mon là il est peut-il une heure une
heure c'est un an 27,5 l'autre nous
mêlons pour le manger chaud que je me
suis un peu les mêmes à friteuse à la
friteuse et l'autre c'est pareil on va
le mettre là car il sera cuit le coût
sera amour en surface il faut qu'on sait
vraiment rien de temps une bonne demi
heure trois quart d'heure est carrément
demi heure au moins demi heure minimum
demi heure et quand ça grésille bien
bien bien mieux comme ça là ça cuit très
bien parce qu'il faut pas que ça brûle
en plus faut pas qu'ils soient trop
saisit quand même et là c'est délicieux
c'était impératif impeccable
jouffroy le cou farci se découpe en
tranches bien épaisse celui-ci se mange
froid
il a été qu un mari celui-ci bien
entendu à était free et le voilà voilà
sa jolie couleur quand il a été bien
free bien qu'ils voient laure manaudou
alors toi tout la chaux quand je dis
donc je connais change un petit peu
enrhumé rien n'est toutefois pas les
bras et reprenaient pas tous nos gens
changent aller le goût est tout à fait
différent
c'est presque un plein de bonbons bon
c'est peu dire
et si on est les cieux alors je vais
vous dire sur le froid dure et courage à
tes les kanak a et essayer de cerner
coup parti dans le courage bon appétit
que jawad l'eau à bientôt et au revoir
[Musique]